I test run for equipment to install to
see the level of preparedness ahead of
Nigeria's general elections
potential voter harun Ibrahim is
confident the poll this year will be
smooth the process will be very perfect
and mostly especially you can vote two
times
I came back for the second time to try
if the machine will still accepting me
but it rejected me political analysis
the real test for the election
commission will come three weeks from
now when millions of Nigeria is queue up
to vote on Election Day
for now though the commission says it's
ready
we are confident in spite of all the
attacks that we've suffered from
that elections will hold on the 25th
that is the very first one of this week
and then of course the second one which
is at the state level
Nigeria says it's deploying more
technology during these elections to
tackle voter fraud and make the process
more transparent than previous ones
what security analysts say technology
alone can't guarantee a credible
election in a country why security
forces are struggling to contain attacks
by armed groups
it will wonder why we are not given both
our police
especially and then our Armed Forces we
are undermined
in the past few weeks the frequency and
ferocity of attacks ahead of Nigeria's
general elections have increased
the election commission itself has been
targeted with critical equipment and
supplies destroyed concerned by the rise
in violence it warned the poll could be
threatened in many areas unless these
attacks are stopped
with only a few weeks to go the violence
hasn't gone away this has created fear
in POTUS
could be intimidated and refused to come
out on Election Day ahmedris al-jazeera
Abuja